it is victory europe day and here in
ukraine it's called remembrance and
reconciliation day and the allies are
once again coming together canadian
prime minister justin trudeau deputy
prime minister christopher friedland and
foreign affairs minister melanie jolie
are here in ukraine they
performed one sign of unity already
going to the canadian embassy which was
shut down about three months ago and
raising the flag a very symbolic move
but officials also spent some time today
outside of the capitol touring some of
the areas that have been destroyed in
attacks by russia including european we
know that canada has been incredibly
involved not only providing ukraine with
defensive weapons but of course money
economic support humanitarian support
canadian mps also recently voted
unanimously in favor of supporting a
motion to call russia's attacks here in
ukraine as genocide we will be speaking
with a number of officials a little bit
later to get their reaction to that tour
today
of course ukraine's president vladimir
zielinski has said many times that he is
grateful for canada's support however
the war is ongoing here in central keefe
it is very quiet but in many other
locations the fighting continues and
today we see more support canadian
officials including the prime minister
here on the ground in ukraine crystal
gamansen global news keith